that's exactly right so this is a party
that we have spoken about before we were
made aware of before and in fact there
has been a photo before of it although
not the one that we've all seen today
released by the mirror newspaper
previously there was evidence because
this was a zoom online quiz it was
around christmas time the prime minister
has said that he did engage in that quiz
not for very long but that staff were
doing it in their offices and those who
were at home were participating this is
a number of photos that have emerged
over the course of this party
investigation but dominic cummings who
we all know as the prime minister's
former senior aide now a thorn in his
side has tweeted that things could well
get worse for boris johnson he said this
afternoon there's way better picks than
that floating around including in the
flat now if it were to come to light
that there were photos taken in boris
johnson's private residence potentially
of him holding a party or gathering when
the rest of the country was observing
very strict regulations indeed i think
that could spell real difficulty for
boris johnson even before we see the
full suit grey report and the full met
police investigation right and kate just
briefly i mean if it does emerge that
there's all these photographs as dominic
cummings says
and the police you know continually
expand this could go on for some time
couldn't it
well for every investigation that they
conduct they will need to take the
proper time to do it you're right and
there's already been concern in fact it
came up during prime minister's
questions today mark harper a
conservative mp asking whether when that
was concluded the met investigation the
full sue gray report would be published
because there are lots of mps in
westminster right now on the
conservative back benches who are
holding their fire if you like waiting
to see what sue grey comes back with in
terms of all the evidence of wrongdoing
rule breaking and anything around those
lines in westminster and downing street
at that time they're waiting for that
because they want to give the prime
minister a fair hearing but you're right
the longer the met police investigate
the longer that report is held up and
the longer potentially those mps have to
wait to consider whether they would like
boris johnson to continue to be their
leader some would say that that's a
benefit to the prime minister because
the longer that he stays in office
potentially some of the fire is taken
out of this argument but it's all up for
grabs and we still don't have a full
date for when the met will report back